apocalypse has always been one of the
most powerful mutants to ever exist in
the history of Marvel Comics and where
he's been missing since the end of house
and powers of X he's finally back what
does that mean I'll explain in this
video so what's going on here is this
initially starts off with a fight
between apocalypse and his wife Genesis
and the fight between the two of them is
basically for leadership of the various
mutants that reside within the dimension
of ameth why is all of this happening in
the first place okay wind the clock back
in Marvel Comics for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with how mutants have
existed within Marvel the mutants that
you know which is Cyclops and Jean Gray
and Magneto and those guys they're not
the only mutants that are out there that
in recent years what we learned is that
within the Marvel Universe on Earth
there was a land called okara it was
just an island that existed out there
and that what had happened is that the
mutant apocalypse and his wife Genesis
had a life there for a time and it was
awesome and they had their kids and so
on and so forth what ended up happening
is that okhara was ultimately invaded by
a being called Annihilation leading an
army of demons now as Apocalypse in
Genesis fought this war what they
started to realize is they couldn't win
against this war of attrition and so
what ended up happening is apocalypse
basically left that place his wife
elected to stay behind and Lead this
Army of mutants in a constant war
against the forces of annihilation and
the entire land of okara was locked away
and sealed away from Earth itself so
that they never had to worry about those
demon forces invading Earth the idea
behind apocalypse existing on Earth all
this time was to constantly test the
mutant population force them to become
better and then once the mutants reached
the best possible form they could
meaning Only the strongest mutants on
earth existed he would lead those
mutants in a war alongside Genesis
against the forces of annihilation and
ultimately win that conflict and so
following the events of house and powers
of X we which we don't really need to
get into here regarding those details
apocalypse ended up traveling back to
okara without his army and has basically
been Leading the People ever since this
is why this fight is happening between
Genesis and apocalypse apocalypse
traveling back here he's effectively
become a philosopher he's more of a good
guy than the person he used to be which
is just super hardcore super powerful
Only the Strong deserve to survive
Genesis and the mutants within this
realm who have only known war see that
as a sign of weakness and so that's why
Genesis is challenging him for ruling of
the realm of okara and so what's so cool
about this is that as the two of them
fight what Genesis reveals is this
long-lost secret that she had never told
her husband that at a pass point in time
Annihilation approached her the leader
of these crazy demons and whatnot
apocalypse was there when it happened
but when a conversation between Genesis
and Annihilation took place it took
place within Genesis mind an
annihilation offered her a possible
outcome right offered her a kind of deal
Genesis ultimately turned it down but
apocalypse had always been led to
believe the deal was not in their favor
that it was effectively surrender and so
he just went along with whatever it was
that she had told him what had actually
happened is that Annihilation had
brokered a peace deal that it was going
to be the end of the war Genesis turned
it down because all the people in the
realm of okara had known was war and
conflict and so in her mind that made
them better and made them stronger it
made them more powerful she had
basically become obsessed with war she
had become obsessed with conflict the
result of this is that when apocalypse
learns the truth he effectively lashes
out he gets incredibly angry and starts
attacking her with even more fervor than
he did before and that's when she
basically reveals to him this is your
inherent weakness one you let your
emotions get the better of you and two
the apocalypse I knew the apocalypse
that I fell in love with would never
become I'm a philosopher he would never
become a person that would preach
whether or not doing whatever needs to
be done is the right mode of action no
he would say if you are not strong
enough to survive you don't deserve to
live there's no arguing that no if ands
or buts that's just the way things are
and so what apocalypse does in one of
the coolest moments here is he actually
ends up taking these two swords that
Genesis has stabbed him with and he
pulls them out and he tells her you fail
to understand me I am a mutant of the
highest order I can control every atom
in my body that's my Mutant gift now
that's an important statement and the
reason why is because within Marvel
Comics the real powers of Apocalypse
have always kind of been ambiguous is he
Immortal does he have the ability to
grow to any size we never really knew
definitively what his actual Powers were
because Marvel had never really given us
a definitive statement to flesh them out
this fixes all that it basically says
that apocalypse can control all the
items in his body it explains why he can
give himself any superhuman ability
outside of reality warping it explains
why it is he can grow or Shrink to any
size why he can presumably teleport
although that's more due to technology
than anything else and it also explains
his immortality and his ability to heal
from virtually anything the fact that he
can just control what his body does or
does not do and so what ends up going on
here is that word reaches the ears of
Genesis that those mutants who have
resided on Earth itself have now
basically created a Rocco here's the
reason why that matters at the end of
Tim's of Swords not every mutant within
the realm of okara stay there some left
but understand every single mutant in
this land is an Omega Level mutant for
those of you guys who don't know what
that means it means they're some of the
strongest mutants in existence each and
every one of them are incredibly
powerful but those mutants who left the
land of okara and chose to travel to
basically Earth there your goal
initially was to blend in and make a
life with all the other mutants that you
know and love Magneto Professor Xavier
and so on and so forth ultimately
because those mutants had known nothing
but War and the goal of the X-Men and
other mutants on krakowa was to
basically create peace on Earth for the
mutant population those two groups could
not coexist and so those mutants who
left okara traveled to Mars and then set
up their own land called arako and so
what's happening here is this Genesis
learning that seemingly mutants have
conquered the world now apocalypse comes
along and he makes this statement and
say no that's not necessarily true but
our mutant population is constantly
being tested that's the differing
Viewpoint between these two in the eyes
of Genesis those mutants who had left
okara and traveled to Mars to basically
form arauco they are by virtue of not
consistently facing War becoming weaker
and her mind they are kind of betrayers
of the ideology of what mutants are
supposed to be constantly facing Wars
constantly improving themselves being
tested over and over and over again and
proving themselves better each and every
time this realization that these mutants
out there on Mars are becoming weaker
comes by way of a woman named Mariana
Stern showing up to effectively Genesis
in a kind of Astral form and revealing
to her the events of Avengers vs X-Men
versus eternals now for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with that story
we covered it you'll find a link to it
down below the like button this was
basically a war where literally the
eternals went to war against the
Avengers and the X-Men it was a pretty
amazing story but what ended up
happening in that story is that an
eternal who had been around for a very
long time named Uranus was sent to Mars
and wiped out something like 90 of the
mutants who lived there and so the fact
that they had been defeated by such a
foe is an indication to Genesis that
they are weak that they're not as strong
as they're supposed to be and that
Apocalypse in his statement of saying I
watched them from a distance they're
constantly being tested they're not
becoming weaker they're becoming
stronger and the eyes of Genesis it's a
lie none of that is true that the
mutants on Earth so the X-Men that
you're aware of they're becoming weaker
that the mutants who left okara and
traveled to Iraq when 90 of their
population were destroyed by Uranus that
shows that they're becoming weaker
because if that fight were to happen
immediately after they left okara they
would have taken out Uranus like that
they would have eliminated that guy no
questions asked and so what she says
after defeating apocalypse is she says
understand you are the weaker of the two
of us I am stronger because all I've
known is war in the time that you spent
on Earth and especially after joining
krakowa you became weak you became a
shell of your former self and in this
weakness you are not fit to lead now
because of the fact that she was able to
defeat apocalypse apocalypse only
respects those who are capable of
defeating him and so he ends up yielding
the fight he doesn't do it out of
disgrace or anything he chooses to yield
on his own terms and that's one of the
cool things because he says if what you
truly wish to do is travel to earth if
you truly wish for me to open the
Gateway for you to leave then I will do
that but understand if you're going
there to incite war you will not find
what you're looking for and in fact you
will find mutants who are far more
powerful than you think than you truly
believe and your death is not but he
presents three krakowan seats one of
these seeds is given directly to Genesis
herself the other seed is kept for
apocalypse and the third one is planted
within the land of okara these seeds are
basically Gates they're doorways right
Genesis having one of these seeds means
she can open a doorway wherever it is
that she's at she plants it in the
ground it sprouts up the doorway opens
she passes through and she'll end up
back here in okara Apocalypse having the
seed basically allows him to do the same
thing and so Genesis essentially passes
through the Gateway which is actually
going to initiate what's called The
Genesis or in Marvel Comics which is
basically a war of Omega Level mutants
some of the most powerful mutants of
existence against the rest of the mutant
population on Earth here's the thing to
understand within Marvel there are
mutants who have been killed that have
not been resurrected who are some of the
most powerful beings in existence a good
example of this is Matthew Malloy he's
dead they prevented him from being born
but this kid had the power to tap into a
completely different dimension of
unlimited power and his level was so
high he could resurrect himself from the
dead it was crazy how powerful he was
this is the kind of thing that Genesis
is going to be facing off against any
number of situations where she travels
to Earth she faces off against the
mutant population someone comes along
they snap her fingers and she ceases to
exist I doubt it'll end that way it's
simply to make the point this girl has
no idea what she's getting into but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end it's awesome to see
apocalypse back thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace